All hell had broken loose.
Sophie could barely believe that she had survived
for this long.
Getting used to one dramatic change in her
life was hard enough, but almost immediately
after, the entire world had seemed to go crazy.
As a result, she now had a whole new existence
to try and adapt to, scavenging for what little
scraps of food she could find in the ruined,
desolate city.
The monsters could appear at any time, day
or night, either one on their own or whole
droves of the nightmarish creatures that had
been let loose on the world.
This life was somehow far more dangerous on
a day-to-day basis than her old one had been…
and given Sophie used to work for the SCP
Foundation, that really was saying something.
Formerly known as Doctor Cartwright, she had
been a researcher at the Foundation for a
number of years.
While she had been far from reaching the upper
echelons of the organization’s most notorious
staff – with the likes of Doctors Jack Bright
and Kain Pathos Crow – nobody could deny
Sophie was an expert when it came to studying
the anomalous.
As much as she understood the importance of
their directive to safeguard humanity, the
Foundation had, first and foremost, been a
job to her.
A means to an end, something to earn a living
from and then move on.
It wasn’t worth giving up everything for,
and when her life needed more focus than her
work, Sophie wasn’t hesitant to step away.
Her mother had fallen ill, terminally, and
as a result, needed around-the-clock care.
So, Doctor Sophie Cartwright had no choice
but to hand in her resignation from the SCP
Foundation.
There were times when she missed it, and moments
after her mother eventually passed that Sophie
considered going back.
But she came to realize it wasn’t the work
itself she missed, not even her co-workers
at the Foundation.
It was the occasional, rare anomaly that was
just a completely harmless little oddity,
not a monstrous abomination.
Often in her new, unfamiliar life of resignation,
Sophie would find herself looking wistfully
at a picture of herself and one such anomaly.
Technically, it was against the Foundation’s
rules to possess any photographic evidence
of SCPs, but Sophie had made sure it didn’t
look like anything out of the ordinary.
The picture had been taken on her phone, and
showed Sophie crouched down, with the face
of a curious, but completely normal-looking
black and grey tabby cat poking up in the
foreground.
Nothing about the picture gave any indication
that the cat, named Josie, was actually missing
her hindquarters and back legs.
SCP-529, as the Foundation had designated
her, was one of the few completely harmless
SCPs in their care, her only anomalous trait
being that her entire back half was missing;
either because it didn’t exist or had somehow
been displaced in another dimension; hence
her nickname, Josie the Half Cat.
Given that she had been allowed to roam freely
around the Foundation facility she was kept
in, Josie had run across Doctor Cartwright
a number of times, the pair of them even becoming
friends.
With a sigh and a smile, Sophie had been looking
at the photo on the day everything went wrong.
Steel-capped boots came rushing up the stairs
and down the corridor to her apartment, worn
by a group of black-clad mercenaries.
You see, unbeknownst to Sophie, at the time
she had tendered her resignation from the
SCP Foundation, a number of the organization’s
higher-ups had also done the same.
While Sophie’s reasons for leaving were
purely personal, the wave of resignations
from other high-ranking Foundation personnel
came as a reaction to something called Project
PNEUMA.
This was an operation that had uncovered a
disturbing truth about the psychosphere – a
shared human unconsciousness – that had
led to the O5 Council proposing a new directive
for the organization.
Those that objected left the Foundation.
Others were killed by their former employer
and its merciless hit squads in cold blood.
Perhaps thanks to some administrative error
filing Sophie’s resignation alongside those
that had left after learning about PNEUMA,
or maybe because the Foundation didn’t want
her extensive knowledge of the anomalous being
used against their newfound directive, they
had sent a Mobile Task Force to her apartment.
Filing down the corridor, the soldiers lifted
a battering ram and swung it forward, shattering
the door, wooden splinters littering the floor
as they breached the entrance.
But Sophie had heard them coming, escaping
as fast as she could, descending a fire escape
ladder until she reached the street below.
At that moment in time, Sophie had no idea
why the Foundation had sent a hit squad out
to kill her.
Of course, the answer to that question quickly
became obvious.
Shortly after, reports came pouring in from
all over the world, broadcast over every news
channel before they were ultimately blocked.
The SCP Foundation had gone public, revealing
its existence to the entire world, and declaring
its new mission statement.
Rather than protecting the world from anomalies,
the Foundation had declared war, calling for
the total and utter extinction of humanity.
While Sophie had no way of knowing the reasons
for the Foundation going rogue, it was clear
that working for them in the past had put
a target on her back.
Luckily, she managed to avoid the MTF coming
after her, getting swept up in a crowd that
was fleeing from something far more horrific:
SCP-682 had been released, and was devouring
people in broad daylight.
The waking nightmare didn’t stop there.
Over the next few months, the Foundation released
a number of dangerous anomalies on the world,
using them to slaughter innocent people in
droves, assassinate world leaders and cripple
organizations like the Global Occult Coalition
to hinder humanity’s chances of fighting
back.
And in amongst it all, living through the
chaos and carnage were tiny pockets of survivors.
Although those too were starting to be rapidly
picked off by the Foundation, deploying more
of their Mobile Task Force operatives or compliant
SCPs to eliminate the refugees.
Sophie had witnessed firsthand the Foundation
attacks, and as a result, had found it best
to keep moving from camp to camp, only staying
with one group of fellow survivors for a few
nights each before moving on.
She wasn’t sure if the Foundation was specifically
attacking the refugee camps she stopped at,
or if it was a continuous, systematic extermination
effort.
She’d been noting down her ponderings in
a half-burned notebook she had found while
scavenging abandoned grocery stores for any
remaining food that was still edible.
A cynical part of her thought it was perhaps
pointless to document what was happening,
but the former Researcher in Sophie wanted
to preserve any information she could about
what the Foundation was subjecting people
to.
If anything, that knowledge might prove useful
to someone in the future…
although ‘what future?’
was a question Sophie Cartwright kept returning
to, with no optimistic answer in sight.
It was easy to miss how things had once been,
to yearn for life to go back the way it once
was, even though that was impossible now that
anomalies were rampaging the world over.
It made sleeping hard, the fear of waking
up to see the face of SCP-682 or SCP-096 staring
back at her the moment she opened her eyes.
One night, it was worse than ever; every sound,
no matter how faint or far away, in Sophie’s
mind, could have been made by a carnivorous
creature, or an approaching Foundation foot
soldier.
A bottle clinked, waking Sophie from her restless
sleep.
Something was nearby, and from the sound of
it, getting closer and closer.
Sitting up in the alleyway she’d been sleeping
in, Sophie looked around her, feeling her
heart thumping against her ribs in fear.
Then, through the dark, she caught the sight
of a pair of beady, reflective eyes, followed
by the sounds of a drawn-out, defensive yowl.
For a second, she wondered if it could be…
no, surely not?
The eyes approached, a small, shadowy form
behind them.
Sophie could barely make it out in the night’s
darkness, even with the glow of distant fires
in the sky on the horizon.
But from what she could see, the creature
approaching her was small, just about smaller
than an average cat; about half the size.
Her fingers trembling, she reached out a hand
towards it as gently as she could, allowing
it to sniff her for a moment.
Then, she felt it duck under her open palm,
letting her stroke up its arched back.
When her hand reached about halfway, Sophie
could feel the slight yield of a barely tangible
back half, which could only mean one thing…
“Josie?”
Sophie asked, holding a sob at the back of
her throat.
The little half-cat replied with a meow, recognizing
the voice of her human friend from the Foundation.
Immediately, she leaped into the former researcher’s
lap, allowing Doctor Cartwright to hold her
and stroke her.
Giving in, so glad to be reunited with Josie,
Sophie started to let out stifled sobbing
sounds – careful not to attract attention,
but allowing herself to be the happiest she’d
felt in the months since this had all started.
Although she had no way of understanding Josie’s
meows, Doctor Cartwright assumed that the
brave little Half Cat had managed to escape
the Foundation facility she used to call home
with relative ease.
And she was right; since Josie was allowed
to roam freely, she had been able to make
a break for it when the Foundation’s MTF
kill squads opened fire on their own personnel
at their various sites across the globe.
The loud noise had caused Josie the Half Cat
to flee and hide, until the sounds of gunfire
and screams had died down.
By the time she emerged from her hiding place,
a number of the anomalies once kept in containment
had now been set loose on the world.
With the facility busted wide open, SCP-529
had taken it upon herself to leave, and had
been surviving in much the same way Sophie
had; scavenging for scraps, passing from one
refugee camp to the next, usually greeted
with curiosity by any ordinary civilian who
had never seen a cat with its entire back
half missing.
Now that they had been tearfully reunited,
Josie and Sophie stuck together on their continuing
travels through the now treacherous and SCP-infested
world.
Sophie’s entries in her makeshift journal
started to take on a much more positive tone;
while it was hard to be entirely optimistic
living through an anomalous apocalypse, her
spirits were at least lifted by having her
little Half Cat companion alongside her.
Josie never seemed to stray too far from Sophie’s
side as they hiked their way across the country.
Occasionally, SCP-529 would climb up her human
friend’s back, and rest on her shoulder
as they traversed more open terrain, her missing
back half making it look like the little Half
Cat was perched precariously on her front
two legs next to Sophie’s head.
And, of course, whenever they stopped for
the night, Josie would sleep curled up and
purring contentedly, right next to Sophie.
When the morning came, she would awaken, stretch
out her front paws with a yawn, then nuzzle
at Sophie’s sleeping face to wake her up.
At first, Doctor Cartwright’s plan had been
to head due West from where she had started,
hoping to reach Yellowstone National Park
and access SCP-2000.
There was a Foundation facility there, hidden
deep underground and filled with all manner
of anomalous technology.
It was all intended to be used in case the
world ended, and the human race was wiped
out, even capable of mass producing new human
beings with customized memories, as well as
holding a backup of all cumulative knowledge
and data on Earth.
Every book ever written, every terabyte of
information on the Internet, everything.
However, passing through another camp, Sophie
and Josie received word from one of the other
survivors.
Apparently, the Foundation had predicted that
somebody with knowledge of SCP-2000 might
try something like that and how it would undermine
their plans to wipe out humanity.
During one of the moments wherein rebelling
groups were able to temporarily restore TV
and Internet service, it was reported that
the Foundation had already put a stop to that
potential option for averting their apocalypse.
They had intentionally triggered an eruption
of the Yellowstone super volcano, totally
obliterating the facility housing SCP-2000
and one of humanity’s last hopes at survival.
“Well, thanks for telling me,” Sophie
sighed.
By now, she had long given up almost all hope
that things would ever be the same again.
But hearing the news about Yellowstone had
extinguished the last little ember of optimism
that she had left.
There was no way back.
Sensing her friend was upset, Josie meowed
at her, either as if to tell Sophie ‘It’s
okay’ or ‘I’m hungry’.
As the pair turned to leave though, the other
survivor called out to them.
“Wait!” they said.
“Look, I heard another rumor.
And it might be a total myth, but there’s
meant to be a sanctuary not far from here.”
“What do you mean ‘sanctuary’?”
Sophie asked.
“Like another camp?
The Foundation will wipe it out within a week.”
“No, not a camp,” the survivor replied.
“It’s just a rumor, but supposedly there’s
a refuge, some place where the SCP Foundation
can’t get to.
Apparently, there’s shelter, as well as
plenty of food and water, probably enough
for you and the little one.”
Sophie looked out of the corner of her eye
at Josie, balanced on her shoulder.
The pair of them had gone weeks without eating
before arriving at this camp, and she had
no idea how long it would be before they reached
the next.
The sight of her Half Cat companion motivated
her; they needed to survive, as long as they
did, the Foundation couldn’t win.
Giving the other survivor a nod, they pointed
her in the right direction.
“That way, few miles at least, but you’ve
gotta get through the forest,” they explained.
“Be careful, the Foundation’s got people
out on patrols over there.
And they’re real weird too, I seen ‘em
doing this strange ritual, letting their commander
stab them, testing whether they can still
feel pain or not.”
Within a few hours, the sun had set, with
both Sophie and Josie deep in the heart of
the woods.
Just like every night since the Foundation
had initiated their war on humanity, every
sound – every snapped twig or rustling of
leaves in the breeze – filled Sophie with
dread.
But this time, at least she knew with certainty
that there were MTF troops nearby.
She could see their flashlights, beams of
light bleeding through between the trees.
Carefully, holding Josie in her arms, she
stepped carefully and as quietly as she could
through the forest.
The Half Cat was trembling, clearly feeling
just as fearful as Sophie was.
The former researcher was praying that her
little friend wouldn’t make a sound; she
knew she wouldn’t be able to help it if
she did, cats did instinctively make defensive
yowls if they felt threatened.
But even the slightest noise from Josie would
give away their position to the MTF sweeping
the area.
“Fan out!”
she heard the task force’s field commander
call.
“Even spread, if there’s anyone here,
you all know what to do.”
Sophie ducked down behind a fallen tree, covering
her own mouth with her free hand, trying to
stop her panicked breathing.
Her only options were to make a break for
it, dash through the forest, and hope she
and Josie weren’t caught… or worse, killed.
Though these days, there was really no difference
between the two.
Or she could wait for the MTF to pass by,
continuing their search.
She had spent months trying to survive in
the anomalous, apocalyptic nightmare, by now,
the Foundation couldn’t have known she was
there.
Their forces were just combing the forest
looking for any survivors they could find.
But if she stayed still, there was still a
chance one of the MTF would find her, and
Josie, and would either alert the others,
or just open fire on the spot.
All things considered, neither option sounded
ideal.
Josie was getting restless, trying to wiggle
free of Sophie’s grip.
The Half Cat’s incorporeal back half meant
Sophie could only hold onto what little underside
her feline friend had.
Slowly, she started to get up, and made her
way out from behind the tree… right into
the path of an MTF trooper’s flashlight.
“Got a live one!” he yelled.
A flash of light and loud bang echoed through
the forest.
The bullet had torn through Sophie’s chest,
narrowly missing her Half Cat, but the noise
of the shot had been more than enough to startle
her.
As Sophie dropped to the forest floor, gripping
her heavily bleeding wound and writhing in
pain, Josie leaped into the air towards the
Foundation operative.
Either in shock, or because she somehow understood
her protector had been shot, the brave little
cat started clawing at the soldier’s face.
Despite her sharp front claws tearing at him,
leaving red lines over his face, the armed
man didn’t react; it was as if he couldn’t
feel pain at all.
The MTF trooper gripped Josie by her neck
fur, pulling her away from him.
Before he could reach for his sidearm, someone
charged at him, knocking the Foundation operator
over.
Another shot rang out as he fell, tackled
by Sophie.
Meanwhile, Josie had dropped to the ground,
landing on her two visible feet and hissing
at the soldier.
Scrambling to her feet, Sophie picked up Josie
and ran, the sounds of the rest of the task
force receding into the distance behind her.
The little Half Cat was looking back over
her human friend’s shoulder, watching as
the sweeping flashlights of the MTF kill squad
fanned between the trees, until they eventually
disappeared from view.
Her earlier adrenaline spike began to drop
sharply in time with the gradual rise of the
sun.
Sophie had long since slowed down, certain
that she’d been able to give the Foundation’s
foot soldiers the slip.
Josie had taken her favorite perch on Sophie’s
shoulder again, meaning she could use her
hands to apply pressure to her two wounds.
But with every step, the former researcher
could feel her limbs getting heavier.
Her pulse, which had drummed faster than ever
as her and her Half Cat had fled, was now
slowing down with every fading beat.
She was tired, so much that she could barely
keep her head up.
Until, eventually, Sophie had to stop.
She sat at the edge of a lake in the middle
of the forest, exhaustedly trying to catch
her breath.
Calmly, Josie hopped off her shoulder and
sat down at her side, licking her paw and
cleaning behind her ears.
Sophie looked at her little friend and smiled,
feeling a tear run down her face.
She reached into her bag and produced her
journal, tearing out a page and scrawling
down a note with the last of her strength.
“To whoever finds this Half Cat: her name
is Josie.
She’s my only friend left in the whole world.
I’ve taken care of her for as long as I
can, but I’ll be dead soon.
Please take care of her for me, take her to
safety.
Be good to her and she’ll be good to you.
And if you scavenge any cheese, only give
her a little as a treat.”
After tying the note to Josie’s midsection,
so it rested atop her semi-corporeal back
half, Sophie looked around one last time.
The lake was calm, a tiny pocket of remaining
peace in a world gone mad, overrun with anomalies.
“Guess we did make it to a sanctuary after
all, Josie,” she whispered weakly.
Giving her little Half Cat one last scratch
behind the ears, Josie meowed gratefully.
Finally, unable to keep her eyes open and
her head up any longer, Sophie Cartwright
let herself drift off.
Josie was left meowing at her friend to wake
up.
She sat with her all day; she didn’t move,
didn’t even wake up when Josie nuzzled her
face against hers like she had before.
Sophie’s face felt much colder now against
the confused Half Cat’s fur.
Eventually, Josie wandered off into the forest,
towards an uncertain future.
Maybe, if this future wasn’t set in stone,
if it could be reset, then Josie the Half
Cat would see her friend Sophie again…
Now go and check out “SCP-5000 THE FULL
STORY COMPILATION” if you want to know more
about the events that led up now.
Or, take a little trip back in time and spend
a day with Josie the Half Cat in “IS SCP-999
NO LONGER THE CUTEST SCP?
SCP-529 JOSIE THE HALF CAT”.